[Music]
mm what is up everyone welcome to
simulation we have an awesome episode
today hello we are going to be talking
about comedy we're gonna be talking
about science we have epic Varia
comedians joining us today Florentine
attend ah say Justin Lucas thank you for
coming on to the show thank thank you
thank you thank you yes it's been the
and these two are friends these two go
back I was wiping Ellen so so here's so
here's something really cool so I've
known you guys now for almost two years
if we had a couple productions that we
did together on the science comedy show
Eureka together that was super fun you
guys have exceptional chemistry you also
have backgrounds in health and science
which also adds you know gives you that
flavor of being able to talk about
comedy and write comedy but also have it
from a science perspective illiterate
perspective and sciences which is
exciting okay so this is this is really
for me this is awesome because this is
one of our first shows that we're doing
on comedy the first show really that
we're making a comedy show there's a lot
happening in the world of comedy Angela
and comedy itself has been a it's a path
it's a path that is it's tough because
you can't just break through as a comic
you have to take you have to usually
work multiple jobs I want to hear about
some of your journeys first in the
comedy space and then we'll talk about
so what's going on in the current comedy
scene and some of the some itako and one
puck some of the pressing science topics
at first I work from our sponsor
and we're back thank you they were
watching stimulation we forgot to put
the tea on no stimulations the late
night show tell me when did you guys
first start in comedy how did you guys
even know who was that it's Ron in
Hebrew hello okay my name is for Tina
my name is Lauren Tina - nah see not
tonight I started no my name is Justin
Lucas I started comedy in 2011 I think
it was March of 2011 and have been doing
it ever since I initially started at San
Francisco comedy college SFCC so it is
my alma mater and I was successful at it
and I had people who like me and SFCC
and I was doing other open mics people
like me from there and I ended from word
of mouth and mouth of word I was able to
get booked other different shows and I
just started developing my comedy and I
do I talk about my family I talk about
my past college high school and family a
family and what else why do I do
different voices and I talked about my
healthcare experience and it's really
fun just I love it it's just a them if I
don't know I don't know where I'd be if
we weren't for comedy I don't know where
I'd be without comedy probably in my
three-floor mansion it's love not love
so okay so before we unpack how you
actually get through the process maybe
writing and coming up with these stories
let's ask with Florentina when did you
get started with it
well differently on the streets of San
Francisco by OMG just like on a heroin
bender just when I heard comedy from the
inside no I'm kidding I started comedy
three years ago and three years old the
reason that I started comedy was bit sad
I was at work and I had a panic attack I
was really stressed at work and so I was
home for a few days and I just found
myself writing jokes mmm and my husband
was like just try comedy why don't you
do it you've been talked to you and I
had been talking about it for such a
long time and then when I think it was a
few nights later we had a friend over
and I was telling them how I want to do
comedy and she told me about the same as
up so you said yeah ffcc so I did a
class and I and I think it's useful
because my first that was horrible
totally the really nice part of that was
that I wasn't at a club or anywhere
people could see yeah like let it got
out of the way you know and so and also
it did open up other avenues because I
had no idea where where to do comedy
even I thought oh I just go to the
punchline for a degree in comedy and
then supply two different jobs quick
point I would like to add to that
because that FS SCC and I'm promoting
Association but it is a safe environment
and that if you were to do like an open
mic for the first time in parts of San
Francisco or different venues in San
Francisco there is that danger of being
completely deterred from doing comedy
because you might bomb in front of a
crowd which I totally did in the first
however at first you know two shows the
bombing is normal with basically
everything we do absolutely
until we get politics comedy everything
politics comedy war a lot of failure but
I will say although they you really have
to get out of that environment that safe
environment and then just do it yeah
right after I did the course I'm like
okay like let me do these open mics and
get more into real-world situations
where you are also working with a crowd
and and you know interacting with them
as well so yeah I've been doing it ever
since so this is a good place to pick up
so you had a panic attack and then you
went and started working on writing
jokes and then there was kind of these
forces like your husband and your
friends that we're like you know go try
go try give it a go and then you did and
you know with Justin to you once you
guys gave it a go there's of course
these just like when you're shooting a
basketball for the first time or you're
learning how to give public speaking
whatever you're doing gardening it just
takes time for you to get good at the
thing so okay so over time you're
getting good you're getting better I
want to know how you first came up with
the materials that you were using you
said that you were using kind of your
family in your history how did you guys
come up with the material and how does
it become funnier over time how do you
work on the delivery of your jokes the
storytelling
[Laughter]
well that that figuring out the process
is also something that you have to
figure out because sometimes it'll an
idea will just come to my head and and
I'll really like a punchline
then I have to kind of reverse engineer
and figure out well in what scenario
would I say that punchline but a lot of
the hard work is really just writing
nonsense it not making sense
and then eventually finding some
something good or if you find a promise
to continue writing it waiting for
inspiration is probably not the best way
to go about it because that could be
weeks and weeks until you you find an
idea that you want to explore so are
usually taking of something like a
punchline and then writing a story that
leads you to that well what I'm saying
in the beginning is that that was what I
would try to do and it was a little bit
more difficult whereas now all of every
day I just try to write topics or
something funny that happened and then
you write every day no I know but not
writing full full-on paragraphs of
something but if I if let's say I heard
a funny interaction in front of me at
the coffee shop
I'll write that down real quick and then
maybe when I sit down I'll have at least
a few premises to go off of rather than
oh I want to write now my mind is blank
I can't think of anything I would say
that the best teacher is obviously in
being in front of an IOT audience
because they'll definitely tell you
whether or not you are funny right I
love it the roomful of call me that's
all I ever know then you will never
really know but in front of an audience
that is say for example like paying
audience or even free audiences though
you know and the best teacher that I
found out is your recording of your set
and I think the biggest obstacle that
people that can be note new comedians
and amateur comedians need to get over
and is just being able to record
themselves and actually watch the video
video afterwards yes because you just as
pretty as just as judgmental as you are
with other comedians when the comedian
go up on stage before and after you so
too will you be just as judgmental when
you're reading watching your video and
you can pick up things that were really
good and then be able to edit whatever
did as you need to in order to make it
more precise and on to the next joke and
I've learned that the hard way because
it was only after watching several
videos after how
for many months or years of doing sin of
coming that I realized oh my god I can
actually learn some stuff but I haven't
seen a video of mine for a long time and
even when I do record I'll it will be
like a 10-minute set that I'll only ever
watch like no more than two or three
minutes of it because I'll get too
self-conscious of and judgmental of
something that I performed and wrote
myself and stuff I will like and then
stuff I'll just be too hard on myself so
a huge first step is to go and do an
open mic itself so after you have some
material go and take those leap and do
an open mic and then record yourself at
the open mic so you can use that to get
bad familiar and test the material that
you're writing on the audience let's see
how well they react another thing too
I've learned also that more often than
not you will come up with new stuff
while on stage you might not remember
why when you get off stage that you will
be able to pick up in your video so I've
come up with a lot of different jokes
from just randomly talking to a person
in the audience and riffing yeah or
something comes in mind like an
ambulance I will be off in the
background like oh my rides here or
something I don't know
and then you know coming up with new
stuff that way teach me how much you
like to do crowd work to teach me teach
me how much you like to do crowd work
and kind of what your style is with
crowder cuz that's all improvisational
you can have a couple jokes that you
want to have as an outline through your
talk and then maybe you want to do some
improv with your jokes but also some
problem with the audience so how do you
sort of fit that into the equation
what do you mean like teach you how to
do it no teach me how you add it up
dougies you teach me how to foot high
five I'm here for these mics ears down
exactly so so yeah so what does that
look like to do crowd work how do you
figure out how what percentage of your
time you want to invest in a crowd work
how do you find the right people so you
have to do a 40-minute shadow we have 20
minutes of material the producer that
you could do 40 but you really only have
20 minutes of material material you'll
do
we'll make sure that you can do ground
work and even then if it doesn't have a
big break how crowded work yourself you
can meet that 40-minute quote I think
really good shows some of the best shows
I've seen incorporate mostly riffing off
of what the audience says they're
building on it because the audience
knows that it it's improvised yes or at
least they think they that it is all
improvised because some of your
responses like you might ask someone
how's your day and you might already
know how you're going to answer them but
the audience thinks it's all improvised
and therefore it makes it funnier
because it's spontaneous
yeah and so don't really I feel like the
only way to get good at riffing is to
try it yes and if you consider that the
audience member is your friend and when
you're in a regular conversation you
around your well with your group of
friends you're just trying to make each
other laugh so it's the same format
except there's like you know 50 other
people judging your reaction to whatever
that person is saying yeah no really the
only way is to to do it and feel and I
think it also allows the audience to be
included in whatever comedy you're
actually doing definitely so that means
an extra bonus for us rather than just
listening to comedy we can actually
partake in exactly and you'll also
determine that within the first two
minutes of doing your stand-up comic
like oh [ __ ] they're not getting
material am I allowed to cause yeah of
course
oh thank [ __ ] goodness yeah okay fine
no it is great to incorporate doing you
know riffing with an audience because
one yes it it includes them in your
comedy and also unless they talk to you
yeah unless that's yeah if they if it's
not if your material first of all you
should probably I don't know how we
learned I said SFCC or a comedy colors
or whatever I think it's even been said
by celebrities they always start off
with some of your strongest jokes first
so you can really grab them yeah grab
them um if those aren't working
obviously then yeah let's do some crowd
work
that'll start and when you do crowd work
like you said you're engaging the
audience they're getting excited because
you're actually talking to them they're
part of the show do you come off in a in
like a quite a friendly way you know
like sometimes you can say sometimes
comedians will start and be like how are
you and then you do and then they'll say
something and then they'll immediately
like you said they'll have that it
depends it really depends I feel like
usually if someone in the audience is
being rude and then you're rude back to
them but in a funny way then at least
the rest of the audience laughs because
they're tense because that person is
being annoying and they're looking at us
like what are you gonna do about it yeah
that's right in that case it's fine but
if the whole crowd is cold and then you
pick on one person who's was reluctant
to say anything and then you say
something like yeah why did you guys not
get enough sleep tonight or something
stupid like that people will yeah will
be even more reluctant here your
material that's a huge key you never
want to call the audience out for being
out like oh you guys not good enough
sleep yeah I've seen that comedians do
that I don't think it's a good idea and
I think mr. Chappelle or whoever said or
mr. Chris Rock ended up saying a never
bloom in audience yeah never bloom
hardly always blame yourself for
everything yes for a paying audience too
yeah so okay so then I think that's also
the biggest hurdle new comics what learn
is not blaming the audience because I
even remember yeah not about myself
audience I had such a great set and I
would come off like oh this audience is
so cold this that the other and now it's
always how can I make my set better
exactly yeah like okay that that was
good not great let me fix it I think
initially with brand new comics amateur
comedians they'll start to they'll kind
of go with that nasty like riffing and
which is exactly what I used to do or I
still sometimes do if somebody's being
asked to me in the audience for the most
part though I've been lucky to have only
positive riffers and very like there's
good roofers there's nice actually
friendly rivers and so on really to them
or I am nasty to them but they were
initially being very friendly to me and
I'm nasty back to that Mel apologized me
I'm just kidding I didn't mean it like
that what I meant was what character
because if you are known to be rude and
people are gonna be like be happy that
you're making fun of them because they
know that's your style but I'm
definitely down the line I think another
thing too is that with with stand-up
comedy yes your jokes are funny and yes
you are entertaining but another thing
another element with comedy and
performing live is being likeable yeah
and so that goes with being able to riff
without having to be nasty and resorting
sexual stuff you can say oh that's cool
so does my grandma or I don't know
relate somehow to that person and make
it funny and I think those are the
people who make the best comedians and
being able to make something that's so
that is relatable relatable to everybody
and it's actually on some positive or
friendly note rather than not a nasty
one where everybody's just ganging up on
this one individual but as well that
actually is to me is the best kind of
comedies where I'm walking away laughing
my ass off in learning a lot about just
something that's so relatable to a lot
of people that's usually my favorite a
quick before before we move on to next
up and just a quick thought about crowd
work do you like to visually parse the
audience for things that stand out like
a couple that's maybe really like close
to each other and then you can kind of
like you know poke at them a little
where you see some guy with his baseball
cap on backwards and you're like oh what
is
you know so are you looking for visual
cues as well oh I'll tell you my when
you're riffing you feel like when you
decide okay I'm gonna riff you're like
for at least for me I feel like I have
no time in the world like I cannot pause
and then think what I'm gonna say if it
has to look so natural like you just saw
something in the audience and so usually
that is the response like I'll scan real
quick and for whatever reason my eyes
will stop at someone yes for nothing and
I think the best riffing is reactionary
yeah having to think about it and there
have been moments where I thought where
I had them thought in my mind but it
wasn't able to really articulate it at
that very moment and of course it ends
up getting messed up yeah because if
you're like scanning the crowd and
audience is like noticing you're looking
then they know like oh you couldn't make
that joke you couldn't make that correct
you couldn't make that joke you found
the perfect opportunity yeah okay
now how does one breakthrough in comedy
because right now we can tell Alan hmm
this I would like to think and this is
the answer but you tell you right tell
you mine how does anyone break into
comedy
BRE breakthrough because right now
pretty much anyone that gets involved in
comedy it has to work a job and do
comedy at hard times that's not breaking
through that's not very whoa wouldn't
you say brick would you say breaking
through would be the just the start of
breaking through is when you can do it
full-time and then maybe the next step
is when you actually get to have it
maybe if I don't know if I agree with
that entirely only because I think what
I'm doing Janeane Garofalo hey miss
Garofalo I think we posted it or ended
up saying it like you don't choose your
copy of your comedy chooses you and they
thank you Ron yes and I think when you
submit yourself and you allow yourself
to be completely overtaken with that
that and you realize that after however
many errors because I'm not I'm only now
beginning to realize what my comedy
really is that's I think what an
individual community breaks through you
mean an individual level finding your
voice finding your voice and being able
to harness it at will rather than just
like going on stage and not being
entirely prepared and being able to have
that confidence and know that you in
fact do you have value that you are
funny that you can make a living at this
and regardless of whether or not you are
making a thousand dollars at a private
gig and one 30-minute set you can Friday
oh my god okay are you know or when you
do get it can be 20 minutes over ask me
another 10 minutes of material but when
you do get when you do you know when it
becomes validating from other people
other comedians and other people telling
you that you know you've made my day I
think you a comedian or let's say oh I
you should be on TV or you know wouldn't
you see or if you like you know what a
competition or you've gotten a really
great review written about you
anything's different stages definitely
yeah we are starting out really well
okay when we're talking about breaking
through you mean you definitely mean
like big monetarily
and I would say that now as a comedian
you have to you can't just do comedy
anymore it has to be like comedy and
writing for a for an online article
comedy and videos comedy and talk show
talk comedy in politics like it's always
something else interesting to Brendon
depending on what kind of comic you want
to be that's your break through moment
right like if I wanted to write
political commentary then I guess my
goal would be
right on a show like Samantha bee or
right on a show like The Daily Show so
for me I'll be breaking through yeah
cool from me breaking through also yes
while I do want to write for you know
Saturday Night Live other sketch I do
write sketch comedy here for killing my
Lobster
in San Francisco but I personally would
like to write my own stuff and in fact I
do write my own stuff stand-up comedy
wise and also when it comes to sketch
comedy I've recently started writing
short stories too I'm now getting
confident enough to think that well [ __ ]
that other comic was able to do it and
now have his own show you miss Ellen
DeGeneres No all right Ramona or whoever
it's I'm beginning to develop a an
awareness that it's not impossible for
me to do so many more choices good
whereas before you know I just do comedy
or I'm gonna get my own sitcom about my
family but now it's even like now it's
coming to the point where not just
performing and entertaining by doing
comedy you actually want to send a
message to people you have you realize
too that you have it's a privilege to be
on that stage and talking to people who
actually want to listen to you yes and
it is yes I think so and if you are
going to say something for 15 minutes or
even just five minutes make that [ __ ]
damn good make it good make a damn good
and make it don't spend time and that's
what I see a lot of comics do or
comedians do or they will go up on stage
and they'll do 10 minutes and it's just
complete talking talking there was no
there was any preparedness for it and
they're just speaking or maybe they're
just riffing but there's nothing funny
about the riff that they're doing and I
can't help but think you know what the
[ __ ] are you doing like people are
actually here trying to listen they're
paid they're paying audience one and not
only that but there's other comedians
here who are here who've spot you've
taken you know yeah and that's just so
disrespectful I think and I think that's
just it's that's blasphemous and I think
in just sacrilegious to the article
having said that though people can have
bad totally these are the failures that
lead us up to to the breakthrough so so
you you made this clear it's like when
you have your short sets just make the
absolute best in the short time you have
make as profound of an impact as you can
and then over time your breakthrough
kind of just depends on what you care
about if you
want to you but you should pair your
comedy with writing with video with
politics with something that is edgy
that kind of puts you at the edge of the
different sides of the field and not
just something that can be found
somewhere else like what's the secret
sauce that necessarily edgy I when I
first started I do think that I was
trying to be very edgy just for the sake
of being edgy and now I do appreciate
more the fact that I don't want to I
don't want to shock the audience even
though that's still a good reaction to
to have because the audience has this
tension building up and then eventually
you could release it but I do appreciate
people comics who are like I just want
to make you guys laugh I don't have an
agenda this is just my personality and I
yeah like I don't think you have to be
edgy you and there's literally there are
those a distinction between edgy and the
edge because I think I don't know
exactly what the distinction is but
being on the become beyond like the edge
of a field is what I'm talking about so
you're like at the cutting edge of
whatever aspect of comedy Parks comedy
writing or comedy video that puts it
separates you from other people well I
would say it's it's the opposite it's
it's because there's so many different
venues there's not a really a shortage
there's not like I'm trying to get to
this edge and now I'm here and now so
you have to go to this I mean I go to
I'm able to I guess I'm able to be edgy
or be because I'm a minority I'm a gay
Filipino man with a long beautiful
luscious Fabio like hair and I'm able to
draw on those experiences and then turn
that into my comedy but I think for the
most part regardless of whether or not
you're edgy or minority or you're coming
from the outside perspective and
reflecting that if you are funny yeah
that is key and I think that's what ends
up half
is that I think with a lot of comedians
today I don't even know if I have the
right to speak on this but I think maybe
a lot of comedians today kind of write
stuff and present it and perform it
because it's stuff that they believe or
think that people want to hear versus
just what it's it's a tiff versus
whether or not it's actually funny like
them and I think I think if we came to
that realization that it's okay if it
may offend a couple people because if
you're [ __ ] hilarious and you are
entertaining in you are actually
authentically funny in whatever
offensive way to the [ __ ] minority
idiot who ends up being offended on
behalf of somebody not because they
themselves are Asian but ever becoming
offended on behalf for the Asian person
when somebody does an Asian accent on
stage like myself then that's not what
comedy is I mean it just if you're
[ __ ] authentically funny that's
priority number one and that will trump
anything whether or not it comes to
low-beam no non politically correct or
being offensive or being whatever
perfect transition into political
correctness in comedy and offending
people this has this sort of taken the
last couple of decades of comedy where
you could say what you want and be your
authentic self and and poke at these
sort of areas of society that you want
to like just you know make fun of to
some extent get people to have a little
bit more fun and playfulness around some
of these topics and now today in 2018 we
a lot of people are are just shutting
people down that are trying to make
jokes about about things that I'm
consider not politically correct so tell
us about what you think the role of
political correctness in comedy you
started a little bit in that area Justin
I'd love to know I mean that's not to
say go out and start saying the N word
if your why I didn't get to pay for that
talk about their experience of sexually
harassing the person at work or anything
don't necessarily know things it's funny
then do it know get it I think though
that there is
sometimes it can be taken to an extreme
I think take that with however you take
that however you may like I don't know
that's all I can say that sometimes it
may be taken to its extreme if you're
asking me what can be taken to extreme
an extreme I don't really know exactly
but I think there's a cost when it comes
to a comedian hoping to not offend so
much that they end up losing their
career yeah it is why which is what
every comedian has to think about I
guess when they have a career because we
don't have to worry about it too much
what's that let's take a look at how you
know rosanne or you know bill bird these
different sort of comedians have poked
berries in trouble these these other
like genders right so the fact is you'll
have a woman talking about men or you'll
have a man talking about women and
you'll be kind of stereotyping and
generalizing another gender or another
like white people getting stereotyped or
black people or Asian people or whatever
minority group so what do you what do
you say how does one how does one engage
in fun and lively poking fun at at men
or women or certain cultures or
religions how does one do that in a way
that it can still be if ease up DeBolt
if you are funny about it's no no no if
you go to a comedy show just don't get
so offended don't get ready to be so
offended because I think what's
happening yeah what's this new
phenomenon is we have so much
information online the social media has
definitely changed people's views on
things because you can be offended about
everything
everything I remember there was a time
not not even long ago when there was a
lot there is always like horrible stuff
happening in the world but it's
amplified on social media and there was
something that happened in America some
big tragedy I can't even remember
because there's so much let's say a
school shooting something something of
that nature in America and then people
were like oh my god that's so sad that's
what's sad right and then there were
other people saying like oh yeah talk
about school it wasn't even that day
like we're like oh yeah well this mall
in Africa got blown up how come you're
not talking about that yeah like it
becomes this whole like trumping of like
oh yeah I can get you even more sad or
like you should be outraged about this
there's people like outraged of over not
being we're not being outraged by over
something so imagine like and when it
comes to those kind of I don't want to
say petty quarrels but obviously if it's
on social me it is petty in that sense
where one is presenting something else
and I don't think it's to inform the
other person it's to kind of I don't
know how there's some sense of control
over that other person who might by
saying oh yeah well you're talking about
that school shooting but about this
thing that happened in Africa or are you
trying to educate me about Africa now I
said oh are you just trying to work me
are you trying to get a response out of
me so that we can see how far we can
take this well it's a little bit of
virtue signaling like right like I care
about things but so imagine like how
much times do people spend online like I
would say now that a stupid Apple like
how much screen time do you get for
different stuff I would say some people
work behind a computer and then go back
home right behind a computer just
probably what they're doing right now as
I watch that we're probably part of the
problem as well so imagine like people
are getting themselves worked up and
everything now is like emotion response
like if you look at
everything is to evoke an emotion if
it's an article it can't just be facts
anymore it has to be an emotion so not a
good article so imagine all these people
then they're coming to a comedy show
with all that energy and it just takes
one little word to like edge and just
want to use two words use outrage
culture and virtue signaling and I
thought those two are really important
the reversal signal virtue signal
everything yes so the outreach coverage
culture is what the whole like oh my god
I can't believe you're not paying
attention yes or that I'm trying to
trouble you and then the virtual
signalling is really trying to just
again just show that I care more about
these really important issues happening
around the world than you do and it's
it's it's not treating like the person
across the internet is a divine being
it's treating them like someone that you
can put in a lower bracket of
intelligence than you then you have so
what I see how that's brought to comedy
and how that totally affects comedy if
people are so it's almost as though we
should we should interrupt I guess
they're really charged and maybe a
solution to a lot of this would be that
if we were a little bit more just calm
and we were a little bit more respectful
and we were a little bit more able to
take a joke and we were what is the
intent this is always a really good
question is intent right Justin if I was
to say something like I you know
something about you being gay but I was
to say it in a way that was really
playful and funny and that you were like
I know Alan slums me versus if I was to
say like harshly and aggressively you
would be you'd be like if you'd be like
why are you why do you not probably the
intent of coming to okay but when people
are trying to say what's the intent of
your joke clearly what comics just
trying to be funny so when you're at a
comedy show always assume that the
intent is
laughs to have a laugh not to write but
if you do get pushed to the point of
being a so offended that you have to
yell something out in the middle of
there ten minutes said and I've only
done two or three minutes into it
there's probably something wrong with
you you know if you can't have that self
control zone yeah but if you're gonna
getting offended from something that a
complete stranger saying on stage that
they've never even directed at you
personally but you're being offended on
it to the point where you're actually
stating something that's moving you to
action that is something that is not
okay and I my hypothesis is that we're
now hitting a culture where things are
moving so quick that people respond
quickly like like that scenario I mean
we have our nine-to-five jobs and then
we go home and if you have a family and
then it's I don't know I can't really I
don't know if I can articulate that
perfectly but I feel like when you're at
a comedy show you're you're sharing a
very intimate moment with whomever's in
the room right and you build up a
rapport and you you get to that place
together you feel this energy going
forward and the comedy is great when it
starts to get tricky is when people on
social media dissect one little cuz
usually this is what you'll see you'll
see one little clip the sound biting one
clipped one 30-second clip of an hour
long or two hour long show and people
will go in there little echo chamber
online and and say oh well clearly
they're being racist and all of their
hundred friends and thousands of robot
friends are chiming in like yes of
course that's a yes yes yes yes yes and
so then they feel like god I did such a
good thing like telling the world about
this you know 30-second that's where
there's a divide because whereas before
comics could say whatever the hell they
wanted and
most people wouldn't even hear it unless
they toured around and they went to the
show yeah you can only hear it in that
context and now everything is taken so
out of context it is good it's a good
point and I think that's the difference
it's like you can't can you really
appreciate a comedy show when you're
like in the bathroom watching it on your
phone exactly and it's positively like a
live performance comedies yeah I think
and you're saying that people are taking
things out of context that's become a
huge issue sound biting has become a
huge issue and then you're going into
those echo chambers where people are
trying to virtue signal and say that I'm
proving that this person is not being
politically correct and that that makes
me so much better that I'm pointing that
out yeah like don't go to their show
like you're not exactly obviously there
are going to be people who you don't
agree where they you know respect and
yeah if you're making it a part of if
you're taking the energy and time to
actually make it their lives hell or
somehow interfere with their lives then
that's that's unfortunate you know I
can't think of a comedian that like
really ever offended me like well I'm
lucky that I got I got it yeah but what
you're saying they're just jokes and
they're to make you laugh and yeah
nobody's ever really said anything
having said that that's from a man's
perspective that's a man it's really
true and I think when people forget to
is like for instance even Dave Chappelle
he he's even been accused of I don't
know being what transphobic yeah you
know when you're a comic the only way
you can you can really work on your
craft and get good at a joke is by
trying it out on on a stage and totally
there's a there's a fine line between
sounding offensive
being funny and that is true but then
give that comic a chance to to work it
out you know what people are also
starting to see is like these intimate
shows where even big stars are working
out their bits and you know on topics
that are edgy Gene's evolve in ethics
evolve give people the chance to evolve
their art right no there's no room for
evolution oh no for if you mess up like
there's no no cuff it feels like there's
no coming back like the whole Paula G is
big enough you are banned for life and
that is really scary get stigmatize a
lot easier today because what happens
then is you want to play it more safe
and what I'm hearing a lot is is comics
who are all talking about the same kind
of political things and sometimes a
crowd will just woo by like someone
saying a topic or saying like one little
tidbit that you might hear on the news
and I'm like that that itself is not a
joke but now comics have to play it safe
because they also don't want to be
banned for life and there's a really
harsh community that is social media so
this is this is a really awesome topic
and I'd love to spend more time on it
because the more that we understand this
the more it enables people to be
themselves and to to be able to be funny
and to poke at things in society that
are funny and and really make a
conversation about it rather than be
like these are completely off-topic
things Ron as we transition to the
topics like some of the scientific
topics that I want us to talk about we
have some graphics have you have you
shown any of the images from okay so we
have him we have some cool graphics this
is these are these are images from when
you know we just shows together in the
past
that's me on the left yeah together my
booze my chairs gotten longer photos
from when we were together I got a
Bigfoot ho oh yeah there's Florentino
yeah you weren't on this one but I never
for Tina was there florentine you were
on this one oh that was fun yeah about
cow what was that that was rickshaw stop
yeah yeah yeah so so okay so on the show
on the show we talked a lot to different
scientists and entrepreneurs just like
we did on the science congress show to
people that are at the cutting edge in
AI or in blockchain or biotech or
neuroscience or all these different
fields and so I wonder I want to hear
what your thoughts have been it's been
like a year since we've really unpacked
these subjects and I'm curious and now
there's been a year more in artificial
intelligence and robotics research I
kind of want to start there with you
guys
[Laughter]
oh my god your comedian like to talk
about artificial enter
artic cultural cultural and told
artichoke trio ah or lack thereof
artichoke what do you think about about
it what do you think about AI the maybe
if I thought about it I think I which
now well I I would totally recast Haley
Joel Osment Macaulay Culkin what can I
say have you seen a creepy AI that's
like in Saudi Arabia and her face is
like natural I think so yeah oh no
honestly
may I now a robot in what countries all
right thank you
Wow so yeah so we're working on that's a
big deal because now if you have robots
that are completing tasks four companies
are working on productivity and
organizations you can actually tax them
and then you can tax robots in AI oh my
including objective science its readjust
so begin to me give me give me your
thoughts about artificial intelligence
evolving it to society I do want to hear
about you what you guys think about only
thing that I know about are not even
artificially telling that comes to mind
no 3d houses do you hear about those
like 3d houses can actually printing
printed houses yeah I couldn't can be
made within however many no I know but
that it takes an artificial intelligence
to be able to like you I think no it
would be nice if robots could take over
the laborious jobs so that society can
have time to do what they're more
interested in and I just say but it
would have to be together like I don't I
don't know that America will necessarily
agree to that because we're so different
but I think also to well I don't know a
teeny you're just talking about having
more time to do what we care about
that's it and if we can get the drudgery
of taken away from but I don't even know
by creating artificial intelligence well
that even will that answer that I don't
know because the culture of America is
based on word capitalism and production
and profit so that even if an artificial
intelligence ends up you know doing your
job and then you end up being able to
have more time it's only a matter of
time until you know your rent gets hyper
or something really matter until you say
that you that we would not go and I
didn't go to parks and and I don't I
think the solution goes beyond just the
artificial about being able to find
something - nothing I'm disagreeing with
you but I'm saying that I think there is
a greater a greater
solution or an answer that needs to
that's more
internally instilled rather than on the
outside artificially am I making any
sense well people are hungry they're
willing people are hungry for meaning
and fulfilment in their life and and and
typically we're not we're not going to
find the meaning and fulfillment in like
I don't think it'll be more difficult to
find meaning in fulfillment in life yeah
when you have in many ways right now we
might have this you might have time be
completely open and free for certain
people that have the financial security
but for other people that don't have a
financial security they don't get to do
what they find meaningful for fulfilling
in life and then when you let's say
everybody does have time to do things
that are meaningful and fulfilling
people will still end up choosing to
pursue work okay but what if we're
talking about productivity we and this
kind of goes back to what now there's so
much more arguing and you know like
everybody you can just ask anybody on
the street how they're doing and they'll
respond now with a crisis that's
happening the world I think that we do
have time if to pursue what we want
mm-hmm but now a good excuse to not do
that is being worried about all of these
problems you know and I'm not saying
nothing matters not at all but you can't
like you can't be worried about
everything and and and yet like what are
we really doing about it like we're just
sounding boards for this depressing
topic and then he just yeah you know may
I add to that yeah yeah in that what I
studied in university when I went to
high high school college I went to
university for nursing the only reason
I'd like to say that the reason why I
initially went into it was because I
wanted to help people I know
and then and then I later on in
hindsight thought oh the reason why I
did go into it was you know because I
there was it pays pretty well one and
it's I thought it was rewarding and it
can be rewarding for some people I think
for other people it can be very it's
very you have to have a specific kind of
demeanor in doing nursing if you're
gonna be a good nurse and be technique
stability and security and you got all
those things but I think I just felt my
soul was being completely drowned I
think in waking up at 5:00 in the
morning to hit the 7 a.m. shift holding
to get out at 7 p.m. later on actually
10 o'clock because I had the chart
afterward and so my I was trying until
what I what my idea was I'll get a job
for the next 10 15 years retire and then
we're talking about earlier about how a
lot of people now are just working for
their retirement to get proper health
care and I think the culture of America
in it in and of itself is that it
instills a mindset for an individual to
work constantly so that in the end after
your 30 40 50 years of working as much
as you can in your youth and prime you
will be rewarded and I had to unlearn
all that kind of stuff when I did have a
job and I stopped it entirely and I
pursued stomach comedy I found a love
for it and then other things in
entertainment and the money I I didn't
even think about the money actually I
did initially thought of the money oh my
god what am I gonna become famous I'm
gonna have a movie I wanted my own
sitcom
and I think when I stopped thinking
about the money in and of itself as
being a goal and just rely and just
thinking okay I just want to be the best
comedian that I can be that's when
things started to change for me that's
when I became a more I want to say
authentic individual and being a better
human being being better morally I think
and and kind and funny and that's that's
my own experience and I think that's
what the society has a change in note
that sense rather than relying on other
things to help with your situation I
think it takes an individual person and
an individual experience to really come
to that realization that
No yes money is important but it's not
entirely everything I come from a very
different perspective I guess and that I
do have you know financial stability at
the moment who knows we're all being
next couple years I don't know but until
then I'm gonna ride this out as much as
I can until I have to rely back on doing
nursing because I'm only doing
entertainment full-time now and I am
able to imbibe I buy it and I do now
have a confidence that I never had
before and I think that's priceless
so I think what end of that thank you
all so much yeah meaning and fulfillment
is part of his journey that comes every
moment along the way and it's not
something that happens at the very end
of what we're building and when we're
working on totally and so I totally
agree and okay so now I want to ask this
too as we kind of come to a close what
what do you see because we were just
talking about AI we're talking about
robots for talking about what we're
gonna do with our time what do you see
happening right now with kind of like
the drastic levels of inequality that
we're facing right now and I want to
know what you think wala t that have
been rampant for the last however
billions of years I think account
I mean I think yeah I don't know like
well it it's a very natural evolution of
oh yeah I think so I mean right now
obviously we're in a [ __ ] time with
what's-his-name and mr. 45 is president
but I mean I don't know who knows where
we'll be in the next five to ten years I
think there was a recent article saying
by 2040 Volpe hitting a part of no
return when it comes a crisis all over
the world what year is that again
environmentally it's 2040 or 2050 I
think yeah and the entire world would be
covered under water and I think that was
kind of those economies they it corrects
itself right you when there's too much
power for my talk I mean I usually don't
look at even SARS or Zara's their blood
our actions are yeah these Corrections
have been very bloody in the ass so it
seems like but here's also the positive
- if like having social media is now I
do feel like we
are more empathetic talk to what's
happening around the world and it's also
like a little harder for for the corrupt
to be so the corrupt at the top to stay
corrupt so long because the information
is spreading quicker you know so if
something happens I mean but yes and no
booth in calm for example Colorado for
example I mean all that information got
out there needs to become a justice
well yes that's not one one one one
example doesn't mean that's not
happening and we still don't know what
could happen I look at how much that has
changed and how many more people are
voting locally and who are more
interested in politics and what's going
on in their local government so you know
things are are correct they always
correct themselves one way or another so
eventually with with inequality I don't
know like there there's just so many
studies that's it
that's a you know a person who like a
poor person like myself like if you if
you have money like you you're not gonna
be like twice as how happy if you have
twice as much money you know your
happiness level it doesn't depend on
that and I think it's an individual
thing and but also like a societal thing
to remember not to be so caught up in
consumerism and that is really something
to first of all almost like yeah people
need a place to sleep people need to be
able to like afford to to to live
somewhere would you agree to you guys if
there's not much of a pursuance of art
these days because of how the cultures
set up and that you would do have to
have a nine-to-five pay your bills
go home wake up the next day and that
all that time is kind of directed to and
energy is directed toward just that that
it's hard to kind of do your own thing
that's what we were talking about there
are lots of parts yeah this episode is
well I think in the UK it's different
where people can pursue it but I think
here in a mirror I don't know exactly I
can't say it
but it couldn't because to like no
matter what you want to pursue you need
to go to college absolutely just like
immediately when you get out of college
yeah you're in but but in terms of art
people say well like I had a friend who
is now a very successful nurse but when
we were in nursing school she's like
yeah I love design I wanted to do
actually I actually want to do fashion
but she realized was as much money money
starting off and so that idea and that
thought was just stuck in her head that
she completely no longer pursued it and
just did nursing and she's fine with
nursing but I think she could have been
a damn good designer because I saw some
of her stuff and it breaks my heart to
think oh my god this person could have
been the next you know I guess where
that's where the income inequality also
rears its ugly head - is is that when
you're from a poor background and you
you have a dream to become and do some
or do something in the arts
you really do only have one shot because
if you [ __ ] up yeah you're like in debt
for a really long time yes and you're
like maybe your family's depending on
you maybe you know whatever whatever
kind of situation like you're gonna be
homeless if this doesn't work out and if
you take out a business and you want to
have a fashion a fashion open up a
fashion store store and it fails you're
screwed right you know whereas when
you're rich or you know you do have the
opportunity to like oh and I can always
fall back on whatever
yeah dad's like don't worry about it try
again yeah yeah I mean nothing not at
the same time I dunno people who do not
have the financial income and they still
make it work somehow
and that goo there goes the saying the
starving artists no matter where we are
in the socio-economic hierarchy we want
to help people achieve the dreams or
their visions or whatever they want to
build into the world we talk about this
so much on the show yeah but
unfortunately it feels like the dreams
are like what's the newest clothes
absolutely yeah how exactly the shoes
there's a whole pair that there's a
paradigm shift that has to happen away
from materialism and towards actualizing
some sort of a vision of art or of some
sort of other in a thing and just to add
to that in order to pursue ones are
there has to be this incredible
discipline and focus on just the
individual art itself but because
there's so much distraction with social
media and what's happening in the world
and with advancements in technology it's
very difficult to do that so yeah you
can't have one I don't know about that
but you can't with something progressing
so quickly in terms of technology it's
very difficult to pursue what are you
man well yeah and and figure out
actualization when so many Rascals and
reclaiming and a lot of noise is coming
okay I want to wrap up and ask you guys
a question that we asked on the fence
and mind adjusting the cassette hell
okay thank you let's let's see let's
let's hear your thoughts on yeah I wanna
I'm gonna just I'm gonna just ask let's
see how quickly we can get through these
maybe we can get through them quickly
how many you gonna ask I don't know
we'll see what else do you guys think
that we're alone in the cosmos what
sense can you be a little more in terms
of an intelligent life no it can't be
enough
I don't think so I don't think they
affect I think we lived
multi-dimensional a right now even why
don't you expand on that a bit wouldn't
like in another dimension I'm not for
six I think I mean there's like life
born like well I think there's
definitely I came to think I think I
hadn't expected to share there's nothing
I was very focused I don't know he was
very focused on something I was focused
that maybe after dusk it was I was some
had said and already was just staring at
my window up for at least half an hour
but I started to be able to voluntarily
dilate my pupils I don't know if that's
able of you know I just did it but then
I started seeing [ __ ] that may or may
not have been there that seemed very
real and I think you know we only see
things that are according to whatever
lively - bouncing off of but that's
according to how we pick it up by our
based on our eyes and I think by being
able there's like cats are probably
being able to like cuz it do different
things they can voluntarily I think
people doubt their peoples but that
being said when I did this this is like
maybe month or two months ago like yeah
they were like like eyes and the trees
and [ __ ] I don't know if I was on
glasses these are like you blocking my
pupils right now so they don't kind of
constrict and volume dilate but I think
there are many things that are on this
plane of existence that may or may be
able to feel and pick up on or maybe not
able to see on account of our pupils
totally there's that I mean but
artificial every art although they are
intelligent life outside of our planet
it could be look at the aliens inside of
our gut telling us what to do yeah like
microbes are fascinating but there's
also parts of an orchestra as well I
think they're just like are like are
their land masses under the sheet of ice
that were once inhabited that are
completely covered and who knows what
life forms are there in YouTube glad you
said that you know we don't talk about
these things and I think it's important
I don't dismiss those theories those
suggestions so yeah thank you for the
Arctic it's just yeah there's landmass
under the sheet of ice you know the
[ __ ] life is under secret stuff you
know
you better watch yourself you better
shut your mouth kid we come get you one
time I was on a podcast and we were
talking about Princess Diana's death and
like the conspiracy and our mics like we
could hear this beep no way yeah I
believe the the just just just a just a
full full circle on that thought to
close that out see it's it's a it's
Antarctica the landmass itself was part
of Pangaea and everything that was
connected hundreds of millions of years
ago and then there was life there and so
whatever has been buried we're not quite
sure if we can actually hopefully be
able to recover it was there so there's
a lot of research expeditions a lot of
research and as parts of the Amazon as
well that are just completely covered
under bush that we can't see it's crazy
all this different type of stuff across
the world so still learn about it a
pyramid pyramid do you guys think we're
in a simulation I'm not laughing at that
only because I have thought about that
for a moment computer simulation like
the matrix what do you know I don't
think what does that mean again that
we're dreaming right now and we're
actually there's some kind of like
actual being that's just you'd that
you're an avatar yeah no if I was an
avatar I feel like you're connected
someone would try to lie I think I would
just randomly run into although should I
do that
what is that have you thought that we
were ever even and I will talk about
yeah okay yeah well that's informed like
an obsessive amount to the point where
I'm writing about it a lot
writing about time and oh my god yeah
we'll see that so you've read Immanuel
Kant and you've read a love challenge
yeah I'm sure you love Hunt also
but it was the first person who was a
daddy who was the first philosopher who
ended up thinking that we were
simulation it was at Dakar Hunter Ilan
mad right now
yeah well Dakar was I think therefore I
am I'm not sure if the car was number
one I don't know you should now stand on
the shoulders of giants you know it's
really tough to know these things okay
but what philosopher prior to that the
question is you know the first person
that ever said something I think whoever
thought of the wheel right who's to say
that people before that person didn't
think of the wheel oh I'm sure yeah
that's the whole point is it becomes
really difficult to go back and find a
lineage if I familiar with Alan Moore
okay right overall Watchmen Alan Alan
Moore graphic novelist you know what I'm
worried about
I've seen some video Tube videos but one
of the things that he said that I he
presented a speech where he says that
were nothing but the Holograms from the
outer edge of the universe sure actually
and immerse the figments or actually no
no he just said it it's an interesting
thing to like entertain for at one point
like we're actually just physical
sentiment manifestations of some other
beings thoughts so is that way sure sure
is that way it's an important question
why if we're in a simulation because
then we're not being controlled okay
sorry that well dude there's a lot of
differences why it's important but
probably one of the most important
reasons why it's important is because it
gives you a better understanding of all
the variables that have to be computed
in order for this to exist and how you
could just tweak the different variables
to tweak the existence the fabric of
what we live in so how about how about
we okay last question what do you think
is the most beautiful thing in the world
I had it and then I just that's
interesting how to tear okay the most
beautiful thing in the world
I don't know
I feel like tearing up right now I
actually do what are you thinking about
that's causing you to I don't know are
you asking what is the most beautiful
thing in the world I thing actually I'm
tearing up I don't know I I'm tearing up
probably because I thought I've thought
about that question but if you can't
really explain it with words you can
just have it's just totally
so tell me as much as you can um I think
you just had those in moments of beyond
words and your body can't help but react
the way that I am right now we're in
like tears I think that's the best
answer I can get how have you felt that
before what experience has led you to
feel that feeling I'm scrapping
motivation ayahuasca either from working
with kids doing alright great set Wow no
kids are [ __ ] amazing but especially
when it comes to like what you didn't
think a kid could do that you actually
ever you you yeah just you this it has
to be a single moment well for him for
me and something completely different
are they meant like in the world it is
yeah what's what is the most beautiful
thing in the world it can be a physical
thing doesn't have to be an experience
or a moment it can be whatever I think
as an experience I think just
calculating a moment where your body is
reacting to something that goes beyond
words and I think the most recent one
for me I was just being completely in
awe of what I was looking at I don't
know maybe I was obon lands and I was
looking at the sunset going into the
ocean or into the Sun setting then they
also saw I was so focused that I ended
up seeing in the clouds another city an
actual city that only the light that was
hitting my eyes could actually see it
was a city there was a city there was a
city the end at the very cloudy in the
clouds at the very border between light
and ocean cloud and sea and this one
single thing you can see and I saw
movement
and I think when you allow yourself to
be able to open yourself up to that
being a possibility [ __ ] will happen who
knows if it was ro but it was very real
to me so I'm convinced that yeah this
beyond what we've got to just see a
normal day life and then we [ __ ]
really focus and don't blink for like an
hour straight and then you will see some
weird stuff that you will convince
yourself as real I hadn't said which is
the most beautiful thing and that's very
similar but no no count and for like the
first time and I just remember wanting
to be in a meadow mm-hmm and the most
beautiful thing I had ever experienced
it's usually I mean yeah usually when
you're sitting still and you're focusing
on something notes but I was really
focused on this tree and the way that
the light was hitting it and I was so
focused that the tree looked like the
universe and it was the most beautiful
thing I've ever seen it was amazing
mm-hmm so just feeling that close to
nature I think it's beautiful because
it's rare nowadays like everything is so
lock you
exactly everything's concrete and glass
and metal and all that stuff so what
you're in that moment of digitized
digitized view an amendment of just
being in nature where you will
inevitably see something that will be
beautiful this has been such a pleasure
thank you so much for coming on to the
show thank you for having us I really
appreciate it thanks Allen oh my god is
there also much for joining us this has
been simulation here today under Lord -
yes - over 15th 16th excuse me ladies
and gentlemen if you continue to watch
our program we will have I think think
about this on the way out on the way out
think about the science of comedy think
about how it is really important to take
that leap
and go and create that so good music
either love it so I did tell people
don't think about comedies yes allow
yourself to be competed by whatever
universal don't bling as I'm focused on
the beauty don't try to be funny just
try to be the bride okay
looking at the beautiful tree I'm
actually like oh my god I want to be the
leader yeah I think the biggest mistake
people can make is that people think
that they're separate from what is and
they are not separate you just have to
realize that you were all just one
single thing and that's when you become
one beautiful huge thank you everyone
for tuning in we greatly appreciate it
go and pursue that passion go and
manifest that destiny into the destiny
yes go and go and go and shatter through
those limiting beliefs and get yourself
out there plays and really think about
what goes into what is going into
society with political correctness and
comedy and really start talking more
people about that see we can go and get
not more not online just in real person
yeah yeah also give us a comment below
let us know your thoughts on the episode
also thank you Ron for producing and
directing thank you for hearing us and
we greatly appreciate you coming on the
show thank you so much I want to come
back let us know Marshall oh I have my
vase oh you do bye
[Music]